I have to tell you of all the places
I've been in the world my brief time in
India and I still believe this and I
don't know how you feel about it it is
the most different culture I've ever
been in I've been to a lot of places
yeah but when you're in India and I said
I was in Jaipur and we were driving to a
location and we're going through sort of
the Heart of the City and uh people cars
livestock everything is moving but
there's no there was no uh formalized
flow of traffic everything was moving in
all directions
and I thought it was kind of beautiful I
mean it was it if you surrender to that
you're like this is so completely
different from anything I've experienced
on the planet Earth before yeah and the
people are very beautiful and there's uh
but I I remembered feeling completely
outside my body that this is the moment
you land and then you're driving to the
hotel you're driving around animals on
the street and there's six people on a
on a like a bike yeah you know and it's
it's it's amazing it's incredible you
guys go through three stages right
whenever my friends from abroad come
over it's because I recognize that it is
sensory overload yeah you know it is
total sensory overlooked and people and
and flavors and everything that you
you've experienced in like a a per
capita basis right so they always come
in and my friends are always just kind
of uh glazed over the eyes for the like
the first two days because they've just
never experienced so much in 48 hours
then I meet them like week later and
they're really homesick
did I miss peanut butter or some
like that right and and then right and
then
I miss the peanut butter then you meet
them a week later and they're like I'm
never going back yeah and that's the
that's the off you gotta make it past I
miss a peanut butter stage
I remember I put a lot of peanut butter
in my baseball cap you did you had me
pack it and I kept taking my hands yeah
I wasn't allowed to pack clothes because
I had to pack all your peanut butter
I've had comedians show up to Comedy
festivals with peanut butter in their
suitcases like I had a a female comedian
from La show up with like bread and
peanut butter and I'm like
we have a billion people we're feeding
each other you know like we and then she
went on to eat every local thing that
she could eat in like under 10 minutes
yeah but yeah
the uh yeah you know it's interesting
because we love doing travel shows and
uh I really wanted to go to India and do
a whole travel show yeah but
um and I would still like to do that I
remember the government uh was very much
like well what are you going to do well
you know we go to all these different
countries and I am I I I don't want to
diss the country I want to go there and
meet the people and and and make
uh comedy with them I don't want it to
be uh making fun of them
um and so but I I did notice that uh of
all of the governments that we
encountered in India
felt and I know that you've run up
against this they were they want a lot
of assurances about what we're going to
do while we're there they'd like to see
the footage and I thought
I don't know it was it was a different
attitude than I had come across before
do you know what that's about I I
remember when you guys were thinking
about doing uh that because we were
emailing and then
I uh I mean the version that I heard
could be very very different but they
said we're gonna think about permissions
because he shot something here before
right without permissions yes which was
something we which is something that we
didn't even think about but years ago we
did a piece I mean we're talking the old
late night show yeah we did a piece uh
with a writer Andy Blitz and it was a
really funny idea which is he's having
trouble with his computer and so he
unplugs it and he wraps the chord around
it and goes to the airport and then you
see him it's a very expensive piece he
flies to India and then he walks through
the streets and finds the actual place
where the Collins Center is and brings
the computer to the person which we
thought was a really clever idea we're
we were doing this you know show by the
seat of our pants and of course and I
don't think it was insulting at all but
he they just went and they didn't
do the proper paperwork and apparently
so then we were I think 15 or 20 years
later saying hey we'd love to come and
do something that we think is really
respectful and fun about India and they
said you didn't fill out the paperwork
last time and
uh you need to be penalized and at first
we didn't know what they were talking
about and then of course we talked to
Andy Blitz and he's like oh yeah I
didn't fill out any papers
that do that so yeah you can't expect us
to fix your computers and then not have
good memories
you're gonna remember you know
just once I want to see like an American
call in Indian tech place and he'd be
like I need to fix my computer and just
ask me like do you though do you really
need a computer what are you going to do
on it yeah what are you gonna do yeah no
and then just put the phone down
you don't need a computer yeah well I
mean you have found I mean you've uh
very famously uh went up against it it's
hard to comprehend in American society
because we pride ourselves on you can
say whatever you want and people may not
like it but that is your right under the
Constitution
um and I I know you've talked about this
uh a lot but
um so we don't have to dwell on it but
you gave a very uh intelligent and uh
wonderful monologue about India and then
flew there and what happened well
um without saying too much I uh
I was doing a show at the Kennedy Center
and then I ended up making a YouTube
video at the end of it which was a
monologue and ended up uh just and a
very kind of improvised thing when my
wife and I were in DC and we were
looking at some monuments and I was
homesick and I kind of wrote this thing
down at 4 pm before the show and I
showed it to my wife and I'm like should
I do this and she's like yeah what could
happen and then and it's called two
Indies it's called two India's and then
we found a wedding photographer on Yelp
who had a camera and we shot it and we
put it up
and it really just began with like sort
of One News Channel I think we all have
the angry on fire all the time news
channel in in every country and so I put
it up and it went viral for like three
days lots of love and then a news
channel picked it up and they kind of
set everything on fire and so on this
channel people were calling me all sorts
of things and saying cancel his passport
and filing complaints and then when I
landed I was like I don't know how this
is gonna go where did you land what city
in Mumbai Mumbai okay and then
we just kind of buckled down for two
months you know the the theme of the new
special is also sort of if you can find
a way to stay mentally strong through an
outrage cycle you discover that real
life and love is on the way and I think
in moments like that you discover what
it means to be a comic in a certain
sense because
you never think about sort of if you
really focus you're not thinking about
Fair unfair any of these larger things
you're thinking is this funny is there a
joke that can be told about this or a
story that can be told you know for
context I
I cannot wait to hear Chris Rock's five
minutes about the Oscars yeah you know
I've never heard him talk about it tweet
about it post about it because the rule
of being a comic is the first time it
happens it's got to be jokes you know
and so for me it was
feeling bad that I may have led a lot of
people down and also received a lot of
love and saying can I write the joke
that makes you both laugh
um because I take any feedback any
feedback is good feedback and valid
feedback head down mouth shut
and so then I just kind of really dug
deep to write a show about being an
idiot at the center of the show and I
think
two months later after I turned my phone
on and there's a lot of love and
suddenly you're grappling you know it's
a little surreal to not know where you
stand in people's hearts yeah and uh I
wrote a joke which was
um
I was on the home page of the BBC and
there was a big headline that said
comedian polarizes the nation
do you know how badly you have to
up before the British say that you
divided India
that's great right and and so it
acknowledges the up it acknowledges
that both it was polarizing and it now
both sides can hopefully laugh at it and
then I just wrote a show to kind of say
can I take some drama in my life and
pivot it so it brings a lot of people
Joy which I think is the comedian's job
so that's the learning for me this year
is what it means to be a comic truly the
um you know it's interesting because I I
think it takes a lot of discipline and I
commend you for that to go through an
intense experience like that where a lot
of people are upset and remember your
job is comedy because I do think many
people would say
I want to go on the equivalent of Oprah
and and cry it's something that I've uh
I've you know I bumped into Chris not
too long ago Chris Rock and I was
telling him I really commend you on not
yeah
um you know you know everybody you know
Oprah and and every show like that will
do anything to get him to come on and
open up and maybe tear up and cry and it
takes a lot of
um I think discipline and a kind of a
class to say I'm not going to do that
I'm going to wait for my moment and then
do what I do
because you want the end result of it to
be Joy right that is my job at the end
of the day and I
I wouldn't hand over my narrative to
anybody else I wouldn't trust anybody
with my narrative but myself like I
as much as I know what
for instance Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle have gone through
I imagine there will now be a podcast
about the book about the interview about
the documentary
but a comedian doesn't have to go
through that we can just crack a joke
and bring everybody to the table again I
think it's the most beautiful Democratic
of professions in that sense so yeah
that took a while and you just kind of
have to surround yourself with other
Comics you know like I remember I was at
the the cello I think the night that I
was on the news and a comic came up to
me and he was like you know the worst
part is they're calling you a poet
right and and that's such a comedian
response where you at some point you go
okay this is going to be funny someday
yes and then you buckle down did you
um when you went back to India were you
arrested or was it discharged no it was
people file complaints filed compliance
yeah and then the police was like no
we're not you know entertaining and you
never felt physically threatened no I I
don't think there's a more powerful
feeling than feeling like you've let
people down yes you know and so I think
that's the most powerful feeling at the
center of the special like I'd never one
of the things I was important with the
specialist I never want to lionize
myself or victimize myself yeah you know
this is just funny you know I think we
all know uh
the way that I look at it is I never
even referenced the content as such to
me
you can't predict when content content
becomes controversial you know uh but
you can make sure that controversy isn't
your content you know and you can kind
of be the idiot always so I think that's
been the the learning